we're sticking with the phones a little
bit longer 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 next I'm
gonna go to our caller from the 808 area
code caller from 808 please tell us who
you are and what's on your mind today
all right guys great show thanks for
putting me out here my name's bill
just a quick comments about North Korea
the North Korean people and the three
political prisoners that were released
today the release of political prisoners
and peace are obviously political
platforms that progressives usually
strive for so my comment is is that the
warm fuzzy feeling that are the top
supporters or the right meaning may have
in their bellies because of the peace
the upcoming peace free and these
released these three prisoners is it's a
progressive feeling so forward-thinking
feeling so what I'm hoping is that we
can come together with these kinds of
talks in the future like all right so
here's war for example here's the
release of political prisoners these are
what we stand for as progressives let's
talk about it let's bridge the gap
that's bridge the gap let's see what you
guys have and try to work towards a
commonality between the people rather
than you guys are so far over here and
we're so far over here right see that
the peace process can work we see that
it can happen it's taken effect it's
moving forward regardless of who the
quote-unquote leader is it's moving
forward it's moving in a direction that
direction is forward thinking it's a
progressive thought same with the
political prisoners we always strive to
release political prisoners because we
understand certain aspects of the you
know the politics that put them there is
possibly corrupt or tainted or whatnot
so bridging that commonality between the
people based on these event I believe
will take us in a path of unity where we
can all look towards the actual causes
rather than the effects of what's
happening that's all I have to say great
show guys keep it up Thanks
a beautiful message of peace unity and
warm belly feelings from bill alright I
wouldn't even know how to start
responding we're gonna allow that that's
just the filibuster that's not a
question I know yeah that one will cut
that one out a little bit later